yeah welcome to this video this is
coverage of the sink filled cup and yes
that's round three I know that's kind of
old ish but what can you do I assembly
didn't manage any earlier and so the
round three game of the day is released
together with round for basically almost
at the same time um I still want to
cover that round three I don't want to
skip it I simply couldn't do any earlier
my current things that I have to do am
at my home just to take so much time
that I couldn't do it any earlier so
here's round three game of the day um
and for round three I will only look at
that one game for Round four I will
actually do it a little bit differently
I've gotten some feedback and i think i
will at least them briefly talk about
for the four games that I'm not covering
in the detail and then look at one game
on a on a deeper level but for round
three which is actually yeah now not
ancient history but yeah really not that
interesting I just do the one game that
I found most interesting and this is
carlton with white against mdl maxime
Rashi lagrave so Carlton actually
watched my video from round one no
probably not but he went 9 a-3 said that
always feel is better at home when he's
not playing one year for so for once he
went for 93 and MBL is going for g6 base
set up pizza I'm very regular and good
green felt player so that makes sense
we've got g3 and now see 5-ply guess um
transposing into the symmetrical English
and here there are a couple of
interesting move all the wrinkles it's a
for example rather important if white
plays d4 here or later
and one thing is if he is not playing d
for now himself black might get in d5 so
let's say what would started this then
black actually has the possibility to
play d5 himself yeah form something like
that which would resemble a little bit
the game just with colors reversed with
black going 45 so if white wants to play
with d for in this position and open up
the center himself it's actually a good
idea to do it now this is what cards
debt default and Teague stakes and
castles um again important to move order
detail right now has two moves basically
Knight c3 or castles and one important
thing is after castles black can play d5
and equalize completely this is a case
where the total symmetry is also total
equality there are some some some dries
that white has come up with over the
years but they never led anywhere so
this is just equal it's also very boring
but ok at that level they are ok with
the draw with black this can be a
problem in a in a lower level game where
you want to maybe get a fight with black
um council went 93 yeah this is better
because it does a good job in preventing
d5 and now black of course can just play
knight c6 which would be the traditional
line cancelled and so on yeah blackwell
maybe take and this kind of situation
this is some very solid but black has an
alternative here that is fairly very
interesting and a line that I've often
recommended to people for ya stirring up
some trouble Quincy 7 that's quite
interesting like it's looking at that
pawn and really will take it yeah if
white is not reacting in any way let's
say castles then this can really be
captured and it's very questionable if
white has anything
near compensation because blackheads
lost time true but his pawns that I
actually still beg at home yeah cover
the whole six rang there are no
weaknesses that white pieces can easily
occupy yeah so I mean this would be
certainly as I'm compensation if black
head like a 6 plate or e six played with
having not played the moves actually
helping him so this is probably not on
white has to do something with their
pawn and the traditional moopheus be
three if you can call it traditional
that line only came into fashion recent
years black has the funky move d5 that's
really nice yes he takes it such an easy
but what about the other captures Bishop
takes well looks bad and is bad because
of luke t eight yep and white is in a
very awkward pinning situation on the D
file 95 this is really bad my takes pawn
takes Quincy's loses the piece or Bishop
takes and now e six somewhere somewhere
here maybe and roop the eight and again
why does losing due to his double
problem there of D file and long
diagonal so b3 t five is tricky it is
not bad for white white has this move
but it seems that black is doing quite
okay down um casal came up with
something different you went night to d5
that's a move that has been tested
before and here black normally takes on
d5 something like takes Queen B 6 or
give that check first and then Queen B 6
push-ups III and he if I for example was
a game one how with white against greece
shock from 2014 so that has some had
some prominent players already that
deadline and it seems fairly okay for
black young I mean what maybe has the
typical slight edge very slide but it's
nothing threatening really um Maxie why
she like Ralph I ever did take on c4
after a while I'm interesting what's he
really surprised by the move hmm not so
sure it should be on his agenda yeah if
he goes for that line okay 97 check King
age 8 and white the bishop sorry the
night is trapped on c8 anyway so why
does taking him Luke takes castles yeah
time to take stock what's happening here
in this position it's equal material
after this funny sequence they offer
Queen takes e4 and the night jumping
around it's equal material but white has
the bishop pair and um also a very nice
centralized night there on d4 at the
moment this is somewhat unstable though
black handset Bishop on g7 a
disadvantage on black side is that the
king is on age 8 that means that quite
often you will have to spend an
additional move to get the King into the
plane what we should check is briefly
here what happens if white takes on b7
check oops yeah you have a lot of castle
yet so cousin of course cancelled yeah
so what did mvl do now be 7 is hanging
now for real so he went 90 secs that's
kind of the obvious solution Bishop b3
developing that Bishop and 94 I think
that some a good choice probably like
does some make sure that the bishop Pam
is some is it is going going away now
what really only has one move due to
that combined pressure this is the night
retreat and now black to count III that
makes lots of sense yeah we get rid of
that bishop and now queen is sex
and 95 yeah interesting it's opposite
colored bishops now those two are
obviously opposite colored and it's a
question who some position is more
active white has a slightly more active
position he has got the knight on d5 and
this night is totally understandable by
porn that's a big difference to black
maybe playing Knight d4 at some point as
e3 is kicking the night away so why it
is a little bit better here due to that
fact that night is strong also white
here has possibilities I think we can
put the next couple of moves on the
board yeah thats it's rather logical
black black grabbed on b2 what takes on
b7 here and after we ate there was a
trade and III let's look at this
position one thing then why'd also has
going for him is that if you imagine
that Knights might be traded in the
future then white actually can go with
the bishop to d5 and has a very strong
Bishop position there it covers the a to
pawn sometimes can drop back to be 3 and
it looks at f7 it can actually put some
pressure in the in the neighborhood of
blacks blacks King so this is some slide
advantages for white the black Bishop
however let us unpainted the black
Bishop is centralized only five but does
not attack anything it's this typical
thin air bishop nevertheless its
opposite colored bishops and it's equal
material so blacks chances of of drawing
this position are certainly excellent
rugby to was played and now a for my
cards and the porn was just attacked um
what black certainly would like to do is
to trade off the Knights so that
opposite colored bishops are remaining
on the board the knight on d5 is also
stronger then the nylon is have
1 c 6 i'm sorry that was a was it called
Freudian slip because i wanted to
mention the move 97 now this is some in
fact what AMV outplayed not the only
move though in fact after 97 it seems
that he's suffering a little bit in this
in this position um what moose of this
black half I was looking at night before
trying to trade that but night f4 again
it's a reply and yeah that's a bit
comparable to the game where the night
was only seven um yeah here if black
takes on f4 he takes f is probably a
verse version of the game and we will
see how the game unfolded um so queen is
seven that same moving this and he are
not so sure how wide is supposed to
continue that night is covering those
squares and how it's white going to make
any headway it's it's not easy that blue
cone b2 is fairly active if white trades
with 95 193 I think black certainly can
be can be satisfied with that
development this is maybe a better
defense I think maybe not before keeping
here the Queen with Queenie seven not
taking on a form and looks better to me
than what to mvl that he went 97's
mentioned and no Knight f4 was the
problem reply the queen is attacked and
it doesn't have a good square to go to
yeah if you I mean let's say you know
here yeah you're running into this thing
or possibly Bishop here as well it also
is very awkward and where else am I mean
c6 is covered by the bishop yeah Queen D
693 again it's sorry wrong paint yeah so
it's it's it's tricky it's tricky
already he decided to take that yeah and
that's not something that you play with
flavor II light-hearted because the porn
f warmth is taking away important
squares and you can really see that this
bish
has a pretty long diagonal and you may
ask okay isn't there also the empty
diagonal which is the thin air kind of
phenomenon hmm not here it covers some
squares that are rather important and
what really has some opportunities some
chances to maybe get da porn and if that
happens said wide wins the apron I'm
actually marking that just has a long
delay then the bishop will be a very
huge factor combining the diagonal
control with the ape on running so white
is a little bit better here and the
thing is that this is the very simple
threat now and what to do there's also
rook e1 now looking at those two um I
think Queen B 6 is actually right what
what he did but it cannot really inspire
much confidence cards now he could have
taken on d 7 but he went a five why not
now black cannot take this and screen
the phone let's the rook so why does
winning a tempo in a way and after
Quincy five now we'll take one to seven
so why it is 1 upon that's some
certainly good news however I still
think that black has rather decent
drawing chances um rook 82 was played
and now the interesting move Queen D 3
by cards and he could have played Queens
would be seven yeah as an alternative
the reason for for this movies that
after Luke a five Queen B to chant and
rook see one it's rather awkward he
could have played that trying to play a
six but he played the Louth Queen to the
three and here i was really surprised um
Black now has some has two captures on a
five can take with the Queen I can take
with the rook if you take with the Queen
queendom d 6 or queen d 4 are both
rather uncomfortable queen d 6 for
example just to text this and where are
you going yeah something like this it's
not very hot great and instead of Queen
d6 also a check and the possible
Rickman's intending to checkmate there
on be aight i rather awkward but black
could have taken with the rook and i'm a
bit um i'm surprised that Rashida graph
didn't do that because i think it's
really important to get rid of that
April and the a porn and proves to be a
yeah I mean spoiling the results a
little bit but it proves to be in the
window at the end and it's it's rather
clear that you should get rid of that
porn of course there are there's a huge
probability yeah that maybe black will
lose the apron it's it's rather probable
but it's not clear um that you will lose
four against three in many situations
black will draw that rather comfortably
yeah so I think he should have taken
that pawn but he didn't funny enough I
mean white is better here we shouldn't
be a B shouldn't paint things 2222 into
bright colors for for black but it's a
no it's it's it's a brother better
defense and what happened he played the
King g7 getting that King into into the
play again and now a six and that pawn
now is secured Bishop e7 will always be
a safe way to guard that porn h5 yeah
what black is banking on is the fact
that he's got something going on f2 but
that ultimately and white can address
Bishop to be seven tier Queen for
Rudy to black and just stay he stays on
the second-ranked check back and now I'm
Queenie 5 that's awkward yeah the Queen
has a very strong post on e5 on the
other hand I mean it's hard to tolerate
it there on the other hand if you take
it then of course wider captures with
the f porn it has straight to de-spawn
formation um maybe with hindsight um mvl
shouldn't've trade it but it's not so
easy to do not trade to be honest what
are you going to do away the queen is
attacked on c5 so um yeah I mean baby to
be six or something well white can go
here for for example threatening Queenie
8 not quite sure what black smooth now
is now the queen is very strong the
computer suggests this defense which hmm
well it's not very human as it looks
totally totally unattractive then
something like that was probably the
alternative to the capture which is what
what MVR played but after that it's
probably probably lost yeah rookie to
maybe not the toughest defense but I
don't really see him holding this yeah
like let's say loop here to attack that
white will just put the bishop on b7
keep that keep that configuration intact
and what idea is just to go around or
combine that say rook t7 Bishop g5
attacking this as I said this whole
situation very often comes down to the
bishop activity on d5 white has some
probably a winning position here no
matter what black
Black is doing yeah what MBR plate was
rookie 2 and now Luke be one just out
for Luke be a tour Luke p7 roop the
check first off immediately Ruby 7
picking up the airport and once the
airport is gone that Bishop is a
monstrous supporting piece check h form
and that's it that's the airport yeah
and this is a one one reason why I was
surprised that um he didn't take on a
five because well you cannot really am
envision this precise moves of course
but it's it's quite often the case that
you want to get rid of that loan porn
that there is on the queenside because
that it's a potential passer defending
with a pawn down on one wing like on the
Kings side only it's quite often in fact
possible but if you lose that a pawn and
the remaining a pawn on right side
combined with the power of the bishop
against the light will be decisive so I
think you really should have taken on a
five earlier here it's a it's a
technical task and not really a
difficult one h3 boxing the King a
little bit rube d7 and look a one and
now g4 yeah a7 was also possible but G
for this win so there is really nothing
wrong with it nagi to be out Luke a6
check its blundering stuff I was
actually thinking rook age 3 which is
not exactly bad either but getting your
whole Lucas a bit easier my notes I drew
cage three but I was just seeing that
route d8 also is working yeah so you
will win the HD porn and black after 92
nite f form here rock be three black
reside so a win for cards very important
win for the overall standings of that
event after
is ya miserable start with that loss wyd
loss to to power he has won two games
yea rather lucky lucky man or let's say
the time scramble against the car wanna
was not dependent on on on on the time
yeah it was it was a huge time time
pressure scramble and them anything
could have happened but cousin um what's
the winner then and now we want that
nice game against Maxine bashira graph
um having control all the way of course
you can argue that black gum had better
defensive possibilities but it was never
really a comfortable situation he was
always in some kind of pressure after
that opening had led to a slight
advantage for white ok I keep it at that
for round three that they'd one game
that I was so featuring the other games
to be honest weren't that interesting
there was a game Wesley so with wide
against greece shock wear green shock
was worse a little bit worse for for
quite a while but then at equalized and
then pretty much out of nowhere
blundered a decisive pawn really it was
really a blunder typically typical for
gree shock it was a time travel thing so
Wesley won that game again squeeze shock
and we had three drawers which were had
I mean the games weren't exactly thought
but quite often nothing much happened
they didn't have huge my lights or so
that are worth showing I was actually
thinking if i should show some of the
other games but in that video but i feel
like for around that is gone for one day
asus it's a it doesn't make so much
sense I will rather concentrate my
effort on on doing a longer round 4
recap video ok I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of that game thanks for
watching